من قال أن الضحك هو أفضل
دواء ، فانتقل إلى شيء ما لأنه
على مر السنين وجد العلماء
أن الضحك مفيد لصحتك ، حيث
تشير بعض الدراسات إلى خفض ضغط الدم ،
وقد أظهر باحثون آخرون أنه
قد يكون هناك تأثير على الاستجابة المناعية ، لذلك
ربما  استجابة أفضل لشخص
يعاني من نزلات البرد أو الالتهابات عندما
يضحكون
، وجد الباحثون أنه عندما
تضحك حقًا ، فإنه يفتح الأوعية
الدموية مما يؤدي إلى تقليل الضغط على
قلبك ويمكن أيضًا أن يزعج
باقي الجسم عن طريق إطلاق الإندورفين
من الدماغ  وهذا أمر جيد لأن الإجهاد
يمكن أن يتسبب في زيادة تحميل الدماغ
بالمواد الكيميائية التي يمكن أن تؤدي إلى ارتفاع
ضغط الدم حتى السكتة الدماغية أو النوبة القلبية ،
يمكنك بسهولة مواجهة الاستجابة المجهدة
بالضحك في الواقع
تظهر الأبحاث أن 15 دقيقة في اليوم من
الضحك ضحك حقيقي عميق.  مهم
لقلبك مثل 30 دقيقة من التمارين
ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع الآن هذا لا يعني
ص  يجب عليك تخطي الصالة الرياضية ومشاهدة
أفلام وودي آلن كل يوم ، لكن الضحك
كثيرًا هو أفضل طريقة علاجية للضحك ،
يوصي الأطباء بالبقاء على اتصال
مع من تحبهم وتحبهم ،
وقد أظهرت الدراسات أن الأشخاص الذين لديهم
قاعدة أصدقاء قوية يتمتعون بصحة أفضل
عقليًا وذهنيًا.  جسديًا
للدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا هولي فيفر